après la crise dans les urgences
la situation commence à s'améliorer on
dirait pas que ça va bien on dirait que
ça va mieux c'est vrai qu'il y a moins
de virus en circulation mais la cellule
de crise mise sur pied par le ministre
de la Santé semble aussi porter fruits à
certains endroits selon la médecine
giudy Morris on met un petit peu plus de
pression sur les étages en montée un
petit peu plus vite on laisse pas tout
refouler à l'urgence
capitalisation des alternatives comme le
gap les cliniques d'infirmières
praticienne spécialisées et le 81 c'est
toutes ces mesures là en fait baisser le
volume de façon substantielle aux
urgences entre le 4 décembre et le 23
janvier le nombre de visites ambulatoire
soit ceux qui se déplacent par leur
propre moyen et passer de 7500 à 5600
par jour Québec vient aussi de lancer un
nouveau tableau de bord situation des
urgences est-ce que cette plateforme
permet de faire c'est d'informer non
seulement c'est quoi des temps d'attente
mais surtout quels sont les alternatives
que les Québécois ont dans leur région
cet indicateur dont cinq disponible dès
maintenant comme le nombre de personnes
à l'urgence le temps d'attendre moyen le
temps d'attente pour voir un médecin
parce que oui ça va être vraiment
pratiquement mais au moins ça aide je
suis un petit peu pessimiste là mais je
suis je pense que le taux d'occupation
c'était suffisant mais la nuance est
importante explique le docteur boucher
les patients
pour venir dans un urgence je leur dis
pourquoi vous êtes venu ici mais j'ai
regardé votre taux d'occupation de vos
cils étaient très bas oui mais la salle
d'attente est pleine alors maintenant au
moins la population va avoir ces
chiffres là j'ai utilisé une donnée
alors que ça reflète qui leur était
propre c'est plusieurs il voit un pas
dans la bonne direction il reste que ces
changements sont loin de tout régler le
problème de pénurie de personnel restent
entier et pèse lourd sur le
fonctionnement du réseau ici jacoulerai
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal